dans mon canapé puisque c'est l'occasion
de s'installer et de prendre le temps de
regarder de fouilles et de chercher de
s'intéresser de se cultiver et bien je
vous propose une plateforme qui
s'appelle imago tv en un seul mot même
âge et aux tv.fr et alors c'est une
plateforme très engagé c'est une
plateforme gratuite sur les questions de
la transition écologique de la
transition économique et voilà du monde
dans lequel on vit puis du monde dans
lequel vers lequel on se dirige puisque
la crise climatique est aujourd'hui
quelque chose que tout le monde a bien
en tête
c'est une sélection de plus de 2500
vidéos podcasts émissions de télévision
morceau démissions etc et aussi de
documentaire de cinéma qui sont mis en
accès libre et qui sont catégorisées par
thème alors il ya des thèmes surface il
ya évidemment donc dans les
documentaires et des thèmes sur l'éveil
des consciences les alternatives sur
l'écologie la santé l'alimentation quand
on voit toutes ces choses là alors vous
y retrouverez des films qui sont sortis
en salle 1 vous y retrouverez par
exemple en quête d'autonomie
[Musique]
quel autre film était déjà sorti en
salles en quête de sens par exemple un
des films comme ça
human le film de yann arthus-bertrand
des films qui sont qui posent des
questions sur notre monde qui permettent
d'y réfléchir
et puis tout ça évidemment accompagné de
liens vers des sites et des contenus qui
permettent de réfléchir à toutes ces
choses là et ne pas rester complètement
tout seul sur son canapé
confiné mais de penser le monde pendant
qu'on est confiné